he's Tony Stewart former NASCAR driver
and NBCSN by the way presents the second
race of the Monster Energy NASCAR Cup
Series and that will be Sunday at 2:00
Eastern New Hampshire Motor Speedway
he's Tony Stewart otherwise known as
smoke who joins us in the man cave good
to see you it's good to be here I mean
I've been watching the show a lot you
know and always wondered
we were just talking about how do you
get all this stuff in here do you have a
man cave not this not this but you have
memorabilia I actually have over 200
helmets in a collection in an area in my
basement at mine but are they your
helmets or the other driver no other
drivers so I have some of mine I have
key helmets from the double duty when I
ran the Indy 500 and the coke 600 have
helmets from the championships and then
I have helmets that I've traded with
other drivers and collections that I
bought if you have to leave the house
and you have to grab one thing what
piece of memorabilia are you grabbing I
got to grab the last championship trophy
I hadn't asked her because that was the
hardest one for sure uh that was Carl
Edwards yeah yeah actually one of the
helmets that I have the helmet that I
traded with Carl he gave me the helmet
that he had on the night that we had
them championship battle in 2011 so it's
that's a pretty cool helmet I'm on mine
too
together do you feel retired yeah I love
it
I've been enjoying it but but isn't
there it you talk to athletes and it'll
be the time of the year like spring
training or it'll be you know late
summer for football players but but
right now you don't have that feel or
your body says remember you did this for
a couple of decades well you got to
remember I still go to the track and
then I'm still racing as well so I've
rien probably 50 sprint car races this
year already so I'm still racing a lot
and is that the same though same kind of
feeling it is being at the track is when
it's different is when I get to the cup
races but what's fun about the Cup races
now is I get to see my for drivers and
and the people that I you know a lot of
just like this weekend I'm gonna be
racing on Friday night at Eldora at my
track I'm taking Saturday off to go to a
friend's wedding Marco Andretti is
getting married on Saturday so I'm going
to his wedding on Saturday which I told
him I'm like whoo-hoo
possibly in the right mind gets married
during race yeah I was wondering about
that and then he laughs and he goes
remember my race season ended last week
Oh
so last week was the end of his season
now he's getting married this weekend so
and then I'll go to Loudoun Sunday so
it's um you know and it's fun for me to
go to the Cup races not have to be there
all three days but I get to see
everybody like to see and you know get
to be there for the race and hang out
with their friends could you single out
the best race car driver in the world it
includes Lewis Hamilton or you know the
most talented driver in the world is who
you know the hard part is everybody is
there's there's great drivers in their
discipline what would define the
greatest driver in the world is the guy
that you can take out of his discipline
and get him in something else and him
excel in that as well and that's the
hard part II I've never seen Lewis
Hamilton Drive anything but an f1 car
I've never seen Jimmy Johnson run more
than a cup car and a trophy truck so
there's different guys in different
series that are key guys but that's
what's cool about the Race of Champions
that they do every year and bring them
and they run buggies and four-wheel
drive cars and two-wheel drive cars and
get a chance to see who's the best but
it's it's really hard to pick that one
guy until you get him in different
disciplines and see what they've really
got is anybody been more versatile than
you I think AJ Foyt
AJ Foyt and Mario Andretti are two guys
that beyond a shadow of a doubt of
probably the two most versatile guys
that I've ever seen in my career
but AJ is your hero anything yeah
absolutely did you talk to it I mean how
okay timely
oh yeah he's uh I guess I just got a
message for him a buddy of mine that's
an IndyCar Series and I guess AJ hadn't
been to the racetrack in the last couple
weeks and I guess he dia tried to kill
himself on a tractor flip the tractor
over so that's not the first time he's
had a piece of heavy equipment he didn't
tried to kill himself you know he's off
buddy he's just does he's I don't think
you want to be around him if he's
driving a bulldozer or tract or anything
he's not got a real good track record on
heavy equipment but I it feels like you
would miss that and I don't know what
that competitive juice is but you're
saying you can get that in dirt track
but yeah I get I get my fix with dirt
racing I mean and that's the great thing
I feel like I get the best of both
worlds now I mean I miss dirt track
racing when I
wasn't doing it and so go into the cup
tracks I mean I was busy doing that side
and like that side but now I get to do
the dirt track racing and I still get to
go and I still get just as nervous
before the start of a cup race as an
owners I did as a driver and I think
that's why it doesn't feel so bad
because I still have that same feeling
I'm still nervous for the car and the
teams and the guys and even more so for
the guys on the pit stops now because I
see those guys when the stops over you
know when it when I used to be in the
car I pulled out and was gone and I was
back on the race track doing my deal
well now and these guys get them with a
pit stop I can see if there was a
problem I can see that guy and he's
disappointed and he's frustrated and
then they go and they're trying to look
at the replay of the recording and
trying to figure out what they did wrong
or what happened and what created the
problem so there's there's a lot of
stuff going on that I wasn't used to
seeing that now I'm seeing from a
different perspective as an owner how
difficult were you to deal with when you
were in the car it depends on which crew
chief you ask but I think Greg Zipadelli
probably was the one that said I was
probably the most difficult to handle
him and I were together at Joe Gibbs
Racing for 10 years why were you
difficult I that was when I was a little
bit more rambunctious and I wasn't near
as patient I used to I used to it would
didn't take much to get me really ticked
off did you
so conversations back and forth get
heated during a race oh yeah I mean
zippy and I were like two brothers that
you know he was like the big brother but
we were always fighting with each other
and it was it was because we were both
wanting to win and be the best at what
we did but it's kind of hard to drive at
200 miles an hour and you're yelling at
somebody oh no it's easy I mean I think
it is I can yell up the kids in the back
seat when I'm going 45 you're going a
little bit faster all you got to do is
just push a button on the steering wheel
and you can yell at anybody you want
that has a radio on your frequency so
it's it's not that bad it's a lot of
times it would be after pit stops or
when something would happen on the
racetrack but you know it's like
anything else I mean the first time that
you drove on the interstate and you went
75 you're like wow this is this is
pretty fast
well after you run 200 mile an hour for
18 20 years what's the fastest you ever
went rookie orientation at Indy for my
first Indy 500 I ran
2:37 and the top speed was Larry Curry I
talked to him he said the top speed was
250 at the end of the bachelor-man
so that's that's the fastest I've ever
been in anything what would at some
point you know if you throw a fastball
hundred miles an hour and you see a
fastball hundred miles an hour you
eventually get used to 100 miles an hour
can you get used to 237 miles an hour
yeah you can't yeah I mean especially in
our sport I mean that's what you're
striving for you but can we smash media
who's that I can't teach you to hit a
fastball that's going 100 I can't teach
you to drive 230 miles an hour either
why for the same reason you can't teach
me to hit a hundred mile an hour
fastball but if I start at a hundred and
fifty and I go to 180 I go to 200 let's
say just teaching me how to drive 200
miles and 180 miles no let's put it in
perspective that it'll make sense to you
so Paul papst over here yeah we really
really my really good friend over here
yeah I mean I could teach we could try
to teach him to be you yeah he can't be
you I mean you are you yeah I mean
you're an elite you're an elite person
he can try he can come close Lisa's
closest he can come yeah but he may not
get to where you are it doesn't matter
how much he try there has to be a level
of talent to get you that to where you
want to be so you can get them you know
50 60 percent of the way there but they
have to have the talent to go the rest
of the way what's the first thing that
leaves a driver I think that that uh
that nerve of fearlessness I mean it's a
good thing to have well it's it's kind
of like that common sense where when
you're kid you touch a hot stove and it
burns you the first time you're like
yeah that's that's a kid that doesn't
know what it means to get hurt so a lot
of the young drivers that come in they
haven't had bad crashes yet and those
are the things that make them fearless
and you know that make them have a
little bit of an edge but I think that's
the first thing that a driver loses is
you know when you crash hard a couple
times you know when you get in those
scenarios that you're thinking man this
I know what this feels like if I make
this mistake that's the things that kind
of sometimes get you to reel it back a
little bit but those are also things
that help you win races because your
patient helped you win championships
because you're consistent you don't put
yourself in those scenarios but what's
the crash where you went and I don't
know if it is
it's slow motion well oh yes there's
nothing snow no we're if you're spinning
you're going over no you know turning it
to me that feels like it might be a
little bit slower like when's this going
to end well there's a lot of times it's
it's that way but it doesn't feel slow
because of it it's just because you just
want it to stop because you know when
it's holiday guy I was leading the race
on the last lap at Talladega and went
into turn three and one of the lines got
a run on me and I - I didn't get down
quick enough to get in front of it and I
clipped the guy that was coming down and
it was all my fault but it spun around
and car spun backwards flipped upside
down I landed on top of Paul Menards car
windshield a windshield I was looking at
his lap he was looking up in my lap and
I'm sitting there going this is not this
is not one of those scenarios that's
probably gonna end well so the whole
time that this accident is still going
on you're like just please get over
please get over please get over and I
got passed around from car to car before
it finally got off of people's car and
back on the ground and when it slid oh
stop it's like still move everything I'm
awake life's good welcome back with Tony
Stewart who by the way is joining us on
behalf of Aspen Dental you know here you
aren't you're not even driving anymore
and you got a sponsorship like yeah
everything in life is a sponsorship for
a driver
well you get a member I'm a team owner
too so I've got four teams that that
have to have funding but you know
Aspen's have been a great partner we
have a lot of fun with that group
they've done some great promotions that
we've been at racetracks and just
randomly grabbed race fans and taking
them to the dentist office to get their
teeth clean so it's there's some that we
skipped on purpose because it was gonna
take more than one trip to get them
fixed but Aspen does an awesome job
they've been a great partner and they've
got a great guest art program that
they're working on right now to get race
fans to you know are this this day in
society everything's so busy that we
don't stop to think about simple things
like that and I'm just as guilty as
everybody else but that's the great
thing about Aspen Dental especially for
us we traveling around they have over
600 locations so we're in their system
so it doesn't matter where we go if
they've got an opening in a time slot we
can get in anywhere and get
clean really quick welcome back with
Tony Stewart I want to ask you about the
art of cheating in the art of it the art
of it it isn't because there is an art
yeah I mean there Utley there are people
who spend a whole lot of time thinking
about ways to cheat yeah instead of how
to make their car actually better right
exactly
we'll come back with Tony Stewart
joining us here in the man cave right
after this former NASCAR driver 18 years
49 wins 187 top five you know how much
money you earned no tell me I got you at
a hundred twenty two million two hundred
thirty one thousand six hundred and
seven dollars I wish they would have let
me keep all that how much do you get out
of that a fraction of it less than fifty
percent and then the government takes
their fifty percent of that so you get a
lot less than what that total number is
do you still have the log Mahal like the
yeah yeah that's where my that's where
my helmet collection is down in the
basement there do you have a pond in the
living room a fishing pond well I don't
know we fish in it but we have a trout
stream and that's 1,500 gallons and then
I've got a 5,600 gallon freshwater so
you don't fish know that we have them in
there you're getting married no you're
not getting married we told you that
Paulie
no it was posing the formal question
when are you getting married oh oh I'm
not getting me I'm a survivor but I've
made it 46 years I'm on the endangered
species list as a single male that's
never been married a lot of us had the
over yeah that was pretty much a safe
bet is it you can't find a woman who's
gonna let you have a trout stream in the
living room er well it's too late I
already have it so wait they don't have
that choice at this point they might say
can we can we move or no we're not
trust me that's a portion of the big
chunk of that money that I did make out
of that on your sheet is in that house
so that we're gonna live there did you
read French with Peyton Manning because
you how far do you live from
Indianapolis
I'm only 45 minutes from the stadium so
I wasn't far from Indy I'm just south of
there are you were you friends with
Peyton no we we had done a couple
appearances together but I mean he was
I mean he's larger than life obviously I
mean he was he was somebody I really
looked up to but uh you guys fan oh yeah
oh yeah even now
it's hard to be one now there's where
our Colts suck this year I'll be on no
they do but we we were hoping that it
will change and get better do you have
any you know there were rivalries when
you when you raised but can you like
football players may not like each other
when they play but then they see each
other socially and then they're fine
yeah
is there any spillover like would you
still like to pop somebody now
especially my last year what last year I
thought man this is this is the perfect
opportunity of settling all old debts
and you know it's as you get in that
scenario you're like you know what it
just isn't worth it you know it's
there's times that there's some of those
guys that I raced with that it was the
same deal it's when you're on the
racetrack there you might hate him you
don't like the way they race you don't
like the way they race you but at the
end of day you get out of the car and
then you'll be in a you know behind the
stage for driver intros and you have a
conversation and you're laughing your
guts out listening to them because
they're because they're just a fun
person to be around but it is there's a
difference when you put that helmet on
and you get on the race track there's a
big difference with how you look at
those guys that you're racing with as a
race car driver versus the person they
are outside the car
how did Dale jr. become the face of the
sport for so long you know I think
obviously I mean being the son of one of
the greatest drivers in the history of
the sport is a kickstart to it but Dale
jr. has that personality and has that
appeal to the fans I mean every Sunday
after the race he does a periscope video
and every Sunday after the race I watch
it to see what he's gonna say about the
day because I'm still he's still good
friend of mine and and but I just like
how he engages with people and you know
he he engaged to be Dale jr. and and to
get people that just run up and
literally are bumping into him trying to
get an autograph or a picture I couldn't
deal with it like he does but he's just
so patient with everybody and so patient
with the fans and he's got a great
perspective of the sport because he's
been around it his entire life so to be
around as long as he has and to live as
Dale Earnhardt senior son you get to see
a lot of things and get a pretty good
grasp on the sport but I think he just
is a
you know he's just a great man and a
great personality the art of cheating in
NASCAR what's the best story you ever
heard you don't have to attach names
I think smokey eunuch and what I
remember the story was that he built a
car that size-wise was 7/8 of the of the
original size of that brand of car but
he he was able to somehow make it
smaller where it was more aerodynamic
and it still had the same size motor but
the the art of cheating 20 30 40 years
ago was much more cool than what it is
now because there were so many things
that you could already do but then there
were things that they went way above and
beyond like I said there's nobody in our
sport right now that would even have the
capability to take a car and shrink it
down to 7/8 of the size that's supposed
to be and not get caught with it so but
but they it's like baseball there's
unwritten rules where they sort of
encourage you it's ok if you steal signs
just don't do it with modern technology
like an Apple watch they if you're not
cheating you're not trying was that I
think it's the model well I think
everybody's always looked at the
rulebook and said ok this is what it
says we can and can't do but and how it
started so many years ago was but it
doesn't say that we can't do this so
that's when they would do it and then
NASCAR would get involved or any
sanctioning body would say ok hey you
got are you got to fix that well it
doesn't say that in rulebook well yeah
but we're saying you have to change it
so that's how it all started and and
there's things and they're the guys I
mean still to this day I mean every race
team has something they try to slip
through and see if they can get it
passed but that's that's part of what
makes our sports so cool is it does
leave that ingenuity to it and the
creativeness is like we talked about
earlier we have teams that spend more
time trying to figure out how to cheat
and if they would just take that time or
portion of that time and try to figure
out just to work on their car to make it
better they wouldn't even have to worry
about that side of it but there's guys
that their mindset is they have to have
that to be competitive and to win what's
danica Patrick's future I don't know you
got to ask her I mean it she's got so
much stuff going on
I mean she reminds me a lot of me just
in different categories she gonna stay
in the sport it's a good question I
don't know I don't know what she's I
don't know what she has planned I mean
she's got wineries she's got her yoga
stuff she's got a clothing line she's
working on but I don't see her leaving
the sport I mean she's just she's that
driven and that competitive that I just
can't see her just washing her hands up
and walking away I mean she still wants
to win you thought about working in the
media you know I have but they want you
to shave and they want you to wear ties
and suits and I'm not really assuming
what if they said you don't have to you
don't be in rest in that oh you would
see this is the kind of place that I
could work yeah I could work I think
anybody could work in here well you got
Paul paps
of course anybody can work here it's
it's proof I'm not retired big boy Wow
no neither am i I never retired I just
changed what series that was I was
racing in could you win a race right now
in what NASCAR
under the right circumstances a cup car
sure you could win if we had if we had
the car right yeah could you fill in
would you ever fill in in an emergency
for you two if I and this happened
because of Jeff Gordon having to fill in
last year that it was talked about
internally in our shop by said listen it
better be here some your your leg better
be falling off for me to for me to get
that phone call that I have to get in
the car again so I'm happy with my
decision to not be driving cup cars
because I really am passionate about
going dirt track racing and new and
having my my dirt track in Ohio my to
sprint car teams that I have it's it's a
lot of fun for me to do that but like I
say I get the best of both worlds I get
I got a pretty good balance now what's
worse finishing second and finishing
last Oh second by far by far cuz your
goals you want to win if you finished
last I mean something dramatic happened
to keep you from from even finishing the
race most likely but if you come really
close to it and you didn't accomplish
that goal I mean there's there's times
and you're like yeah well we were better
than third and that's how you try to
convince yourself it's okay but it's
there's a lot of times and you look at
Darlington you look at the 78 team I
mean they they dominated that and
second at the end of the day I mean the
dejection on their face was obvious it
was like it was like somebody kicked his
dog and took his dog home you don't talk
you don't give names you just give
numbers right yeah yeah that's everybody
talks about that's when I went to North
Carolina I realized that they taught
kids how to count by the NASCAR car
numbers that's how they taught the kids
to count really yeah eight was Dale jr.
well then 88 okay you know the name so
back back when I started it with Steve
Park Rusty Wallace
Dale Earnhardt Sterling Marlin
[Laughter]
thanks for joining us I know like you
want to get another plug for Aspen
Dental so fire away no I just think
we're excited I mean there's they're
starting a program that's called get
started and you know as our championship
chase is getting started they're trying
to get the fans amped up about going to
the dentist again and like I said I've
been to a couple of them now and it's
it's really convenient really simple you
get in you get out and they do a great
job so they've got over 600 locations
around the country and it's a great
great company like I said once you get
in their system if you're traveling it
makes it even easier to get your teeth
clean you don't have to wait till you
get home so it's a it's very very
convenient for everybody you could knock
some guy's teeth out like Kurt Busch and
then you could have overpass don't like
it's a naked fix it for that that would
be nice and kind of serve two things
don't good to see you thank you for
joining us and uh have fun today at NBC
the Dan Patrick show weekday mornings on
audience